j'aimerais juste peut-être avoir votre
réaction à la décision euh en tout cas
au au rejet de la résolution du Conseil
de de conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU la résolution brésilienne avec un
vote favorable de la France mais
vraisemblablement un vote contre des
États-Unis euh et un vote de 12
favorable de 12 pays sur 15 en dehors de
la Russie euh à l'instant peut-être
pouvez-vous nous en dire un enfin sur
notamment la position des États-Unis euh
en en effet monsieur le Président je
décrivais tout à l'heure l'état des
l'état des des négociations qui avait
permis d'améliorer le projet de texte
présenté il y a plusieurs jours par le
par le Brésil et de l'améliorer dans le
sens que que je
décrivais le vote et ce vote était
composé d'éléments importants je l'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure et donc nous
avons voté en faveur de ce texte comme
beaucoup d'autres États deux autres
États membres du Conseil de sécurité se
sont abstenus et il y a eu un véau en
effet celui des États-Unis d'Amérique un
véau qu'il leur faudra expliquer parce
que si le texte n'atteignait pas la
perfection des objectifs qu'on pourrait
idéalement fixer une résolution des
Nations Unies de façon à ce que ce texte
amène la désescalade et euh empêche un
engrenage encore plus délicat tout en
rappelant le droit d'Israël à se
défendre il nous a paru suffisamment bon
comme à la majorité des membres du
conseil pour qu' soit voté donc un choix
différent d'e autre qui a été fait par
les États-Unis il faudra qu'il qu'il
l'explique et nous aurions préféré
inutile de le dire un consensus